joie que l'iphone joue c'est d'abord un
art de vivre pour les asiatiques l'art
de vivre sur le feng shui non c'est le
fun chou diaconu notre mode de vie c'est
d'abord d'empêcher les autres de
construire et quand on construit des
courtes ont construit de façon à ce
qu'il soit toujours en situation du
recommencement
c'est une forme dépressive finalement
deuxième élément le fond de chaussée
quoi si le fait que quelqu'un d'essayer
de faire en sorte que l'autre toujours
dépendre de la vidéo faire en sorte
qu'il soit souvent c'est quand on ne se
blesse de dépendance voire de soumission
à notre égard et ce mode de
fonctionnement s écarte ainsi de notre
culture puisque j'ai la chance de
travailler en martinique en guadeloupe
est donc en guyane et j'ai aussi la
chance de travailler les diagonales
violent pour la peine je peux
effectivement comparer le mode de vie
voir comment c'est le mode de vie peut
parfois se retrouver ailleurs
mais en quoi aussi longue qu'un peu
caractéristique et en quoi il faut
avancer speed ailleurs mais ça va être
important c'est comment nous pouvons
avancer que les gentils important mais
d'abord nous la mort loin qui est
d'abord celle qui est prioritaire
alors oui mais quelle solution alors
première solution c'est qu'il faut
d'abord accepter l'idée que nous devons
être peuple de bâtisseurs un peu le
terrain et construisent et par
conséquent chacun doit construire en
forte hausse et moyens pas vouloir
construire plus ou moins ce colloque
selon ses moyens
troisième choix donné l'amour de la
construction en france et à quoi vous
monter une petite petite entreprise
vous êtes salarié essayer de faire au
mieux ce que vous êtes capable de faire
viser l'excellence je crois que au moins
ses trois premières propositions
devraient nous permettre d'aller plus
loin de sortie de cette problématique de
la destruction